hello nice to meet you yeah how are you
good very good
hello everyone a few words this is our
participants of the flight program
something we started new basically
teaching or showing bigger companies how
you can think and act more of like
startups to be more innovative so
there's something you can certainly talk
about so we were sure little bit about
entrepreneurship what could be
motivating sure hello
so I think what's super interesting to
me is the last eight or nine years of my
life have been I've been spending most
of my time with fortune 100 companies
with my agency I think you know without
side railing whatever you're preaching I
think the biggest issue that we who have
a point of view of from the outside of
bigger companies have is sometimes too
much of an ideology you know I've become
unbelievably empathetic to a lot of you
in what what I didn't know coming from a
family business and coming from startup
culture is most of the companies that
are big in the world care about their
finances every 90 days and so you he can
inspire you for the next [ __ ] six
years of your life you can you know
there's nuances that you can pick up on
and there's probably little tactics that
could create you know little moments
within your organization but I'm no
longer delusional about this and I have
no interest in pandering to an ideology
I think all of you know the issue at
hand which is your organization's lack
of appetite for the investment that's
required to make meaningful change
during a macro major macro consumer and
economic shift of the growth of the
Internet I mean this is it's gonna be
very hard for all of us to muster up
enough energy and ability to move these
things and not to make it there's
nothing we can do but I think the
reality is I would say this the most
meaningful conversations I've had with
the biggest of the biggest
these is instead of me pontificating
that you should do this why don't we
have a conversation of what's gonna
happen in the next three to eleven years
whenever it's your time to actually
really get hurt by this when you'll be
willing to do something about it your
companies aren't gonna do [ __ ] until
they have to right so I think the
biggest thing you could do is get them
ready for the marathon right so I think
about it like running if all these they
come in I have no sense of the company's
in a room but if big companies are gonna
be sucked into adjusting to the reality
of a new world I think everybody here
understands that there's not a there's
very few big companies in the world that
don't have most of their money and
energy tied up into an infrastructure
that is becoming less relevant and so
that's why it's gonna happen and so how
do you get them on the treadmill like
what could for the sake of what you're
doing here you got to get your company
on a treadmill or eating a little bit
better not running the marathon yet
right what can you do to make
incremental steps so that when an uber
or Airbnb or real Netflix or a big event
happens in whatever industry in where
and that's what's happening right like
you no matter what you went around and
said I'm in this I mean this in my head
I'm like okay in the next 24 months in
the next 72 months in the next ninety
six months like eventually all of our
numbers are gonna come up like network
television across the globe is dead
because now we have OTT and whether it's
Netflix or something in Asia or
something you know Amazon October having
a satellite in the air is a bad idea
right
having your retailers it's not that
ecommerce is gonna take all the business
it's just that there's enough being done
on Commerce that the leases aren't a
good deal anymore so it doesn't take a
look I think the other thing to think
about as a theme is it doesn't take a
it's not like whatever you're doing gets
replaced by some other new thing it's it
doesn't take a lot of market share taken
away from you for the whole thing to
break so those are the themes that I see
going on here and so I think you know I
think you
for you than you and like the key is not
for us to be ideological and say you
they get you know we think they don't
get it they get it they're just playing
by different rules and they can't get it
done so I think instead of spending all
this time on ideology that is great for
a one day of inspiration but the next
Thursday you can't do anything about it
I challenge you guys to think about
curriculum that actually makes it
something practical that can move them
right cuz it's coming for real yeah you
know for me because I've been in a long
time
it was questioned a decade ago is how
big is it a fad is it small it hasn't
even been the Internet is this is the
secondary life this is the real life
just is and terror to that point to that
point a lot of a lot of people are
making business decisions based on how
they feel about it now that's dangerous
you know it's very dangerous to make
business decisions based on your
personal point of view of technology and
that's that's what I don't know if you
guys got to see my speech or not but
that's what I was trying to talk about
up there which is like be practical like
know what you're actually talking about
like I don't know what you're talking
probably organizational but that's why I
spend time on marketing because
marketing you can actually change the
money you can actually move a million
dollars from Google AdWords to Facebook
or from bus stop ads to Instagram
whereas a lot of the heady [ __ ] it's so
inherently deep in the organization you
can't move it because there's a human
that's gonna stop you so that's what I
would that's as you think about trying
to bring value it's it's more
practicality because I think there's a
little bit about dasa be amongst us in
the startup world they know they just
can't do anything about it
I think HR is a very interesting place
as I've learned more about big business
HR is a place where companies waste a
lot of money you know nobody kind of
questions the HR budget for employees it
looks good but then the money is being
spent on things that are just checking
the box so one of the places I've seen
fruitful for organizations if you're
lucky enough to have it open minded or
flexible HR lead is sheer he you can
team up with them and maybe you're in it
or maybe a part like I don't know again
I don't have context for the room but
that's oftentimes a place where I've
seen some really interesting thing
because then you can go into education
and ultimately I don't love the way
school is done in the world but
education is the game and the funny part
is I made a comment up there a lot of
you have opinions about Facebook ads and
Instagram ads but you've never run one
the biggest thing that I the reason I
think I have a lot of success is I'm a
businessman and then I care about all
this stuff
so when I get to the c-suite or the
board of big companies I talk about
business and when they get even a little
educated about business not it's cool
not we should do it when it's about the
P&L when it's about money they start
listening a lot more 100% to me every
time I talk about HR every time I talk
about innovation every every time I talk
to the CFO the reason I believe in
people is turnover is expensive so take
care of your people
it's money the reason I believe in
innovation is you're wasting so much
money is a big company and all these
other things are you not willing to put
a little money into where we're going so
I think that's the other thing is make
none of this ideological make all of it
financial cuz that's what companies
respond to
[Music]